foreign
[Music]
vlogger
so let's get after it and have us
some good [ __ ] bread
well Chris Cuomo is now getting some
podcast guests on
are you ready for I mean there's a few
but this seemed to be the one that I
thought would be the most fun and it
ain't gonna be that [ __ ] sucker Don
Lemon either no it isn't
[ __ ] him
Professor dude what a pleasure ah black
science man
ah is he gonna tell us about the the
quantum impossibility of Santa Claus and
Jesus it couldn't have happened and it
wouldn't have been he might but Kris
Chrome won't understand anything coming
out of his mouth
foreign
of existence and then it because and
then it's it's an atom right so if you
ever think maybe like the atom was like
uh you know an analogy if you will for
the atom
it's a heroin think of it right now I
can't think of the licorice booze
poured a little sambuca and some
espresso what do you think about the
Adam thing he goes so yeah what are your
name what do you think about the quantum
possibilities of atoms I keep telling
you I'm Keenan Thompson
got all them animals on that boat I'm
the dude from SNL I'm Keenan why are you
talking I am not who you think I am oh
you're saying yeah it's like I'm here
with Neil degrass I said no I'm the guy
from SNL
yeah now what I have just said in the
introduction I will redouble them now I
would like to read a passage from uh
Ecclesiastes oh no come on no he's not
he'll be hilarious which is this is a
love letter I'm going to read a passage
from my book let's get after it the
Memoirs of Chris Cuomo he's like this is
a love letter hang on I wrote this to my
wife before we got married dear Linda
your boobs are incredible and then the
first thing the other grass seism is I
says I got to ask you a question why is
there a dead bird by your keys I need no
fight now it's a skeleton why is there a
little tiny bird skeleton on the floor I
was supposed to do that but then I got
to the gym and I forgot I was leg day
the whole thing don't worry about it
to Neil deGrasse Tyson because for over
20 years I have been saying a massive
package that's a lot of years to be a
[ __ ] Chris it seems like too many in 20
years of being a douchebag
we need our best and our brightest to
talk about what's happening in the
Public Square and the best we could do
is Neil deGrasse Dyson so here we are
yeah we we need to reach out to the best
and brightest and I could not get Dr
Robert Malone on this show so here you
are
apparently when you call him an [ __ ]
for two years doing a pandemic he does
not like you after you leave CNN yeah uh
apparently when you tell the guy who
invented the MRNA vaccine that he's a
[ __ ] due to do and he should trust
real scientists hey doesn't take it so
good
turns out he was my primary physician I
didn't put two and two together so I
need a new doctor
could you imagine like back in the day
if if they caught like if the country
started mocking Henry Ford for having an
opinion about cars or Jews
he comes out and he's like yeah I don't
think that car is going to be very safe
I think we need to add some more safety
requirements yeah okay what do you know
about cars Mr car guys that's all
and you are one of our best and
brightest what has he done
no no besides besides people yeah I know
that's my point besides being the
voiceover guy for Cosmos and being
Rogan's Cosmo and being [ __ ] Rogan's
best friend what's the point what does
he do what has he done for the greater
he's just a guy a guy from Academia who
was very good he's the Dane Cook of
Academia he was very good at [ __ ]
social media and had a lot of sexual
assault allegations so yeah they're very
similar you're right they did
no country
no a good thing and this book which you
must read and you know me I don't tell
you you know me I can't read you know me
I'm not a reader I'm not reading my best
yeah
so anyway uh I'm gonna read uh I'm gonna
read a passage from the book it says
here uh and he's putting his finger
under the words
the universe is infinite so like what
does that mean am I gonna live forever
doc
[Laughter]
so you uh went to Harvard University
right then you went to Colombia
uh did you find it difficult uh to
become science man uh at Harvard as a
black
no comment
well I like if you stopped referring to
referring to me as a black I would be
great if you started with that so when
you were growing up in the ghetto and
the grass types it's like my dad was a
sociologist
[Laughter]
I know you don't you don't see a lot of
moving on scientists what's that what's
that like
uh my my mom worked for the U.S
Department of Health and education are
you sure you don't mean your mom or for
you not for the United States Postal
Service
do you mean the DMV right right
obviously let's be real you're pretty
sure I snap a gum and put everybody on
hold it's like I used to tell my brother
Andrew yeah that Neil Guy pretty smart
for a black guy he's like I what I grew
up in an opera mini class home in
Manhattan
hey hey my Uncle Nino uh my Uncle Nino
used to tell me uh that you you guys uh
snapped chickens necks for luck what's
up with that is that true or what
hey I heard you were wrestling you want
to go real quick with me 10 minutes on
the round you want to roll around a
little bit see who's stronger so your
family grew up in the Bronx I mean well
I mean obvious obvious I mean we're not
letting you over here in Bensonhurst
so where'd you live do you live in that
part where they took a picture of that
Nas album is that the part you were at I
don't know what part you're from yeah
what are you from Queen's bridge yet I
believe it's called the bridge is never
over that's what they told me am I gonna
live forever
he goes back to immortality
all right so let's say that I've been
hypothetically let's see I'm gonna do an
experiment on bringing a bird back to
life
[Laughter]
so Neil deGrasse Tyson is joining me
today please help me bring this bird
back to life it's like what the what
yeah you got some kind of like science
machine I could bring this bird back
alive I feel terrible how many car
batteries who got attached to a bird
like I got two was it three or four how
many I fed a couple to him was that a
good thing
hmm
oh [ __ ]
you to read a lot of books this book is
so smart if you want to think if you
want to care and I know I just said this
to you but when you were like I don't
read a lot of books that aren't double
space so like this told me is a big deal
this is a big deal to me Neil I gotta
tell you I gotta tell you bro I was I
was reading your book on this [ __ ]
I never had a more enlightened
insightful experience it was like I was
[ __ ] but I was learning about the
universe
[Laughter]
Pete thinks it helps
we have someone who knows how to think
think about yourself who's good who's
got better traps me and Joe Rogan who
got a better body Lobster hey Pop I was
gonna say I was just trying to say that
he pops his shirt right off what are you
doing what do you think Wardlow doing
the peck [ __ ] jumps what are you what
do you what do you think does Rogan do
the peck jumps
I look like Rick Rude over here and it's
Prime hey you want to see these two
electrons Circle in a [ __ ] hunk
that's a proton that's a neutron oh
what am I doing here and I thought Joe
Rogan was a dumb Meathead he makes fight
he made it this makes [ __ ] going on
Rogue and feel like hanging out with
Voltaire you know what the worst part is
he had to go through his probably beaded
curtain to get down to his [ __ ]
basement Studio
hey that's vintage I used to my uncle
used to have that ass house only thing
he left me [ __ ]
so can like uh can Italian can Italian
Jesus make a meatball so big he can't
eat
[Laughter]
it would it's a meatball like some kind
of star was just constantly expanding
you could just make a like enough
meatball to feed everybody right uh I
have a question Chris are all your
questions gonna be meatball based
because it's been like the third one and
I don't are you hungry I asked for water
like an hour ago I had to get that and
he keeps giving him that same Sambuca
instead I can't I cannot drink this I
cannot drink this
you know this is supposed to be a
digestive right you're only supposed to
have like a shot of this afternoon too
sweet it's the problem I'm having with
this it's too sweet
oh [ __ ] the only thing in my fridge is
that got sambuca and Pedialyte from when
I drink too much Sambuca
it's a vicious cycle yeah you know you
try getting fired from CNN
what you're just going on you try waking
up out of [ __ ] three million dollar a
year contract with a dead bird in your
pocket you ever go through that now
I've [ __ ] lived some hard times which
reminds me I gotta remind my wife to
take that dead bird out of my [ __ ]
coat
oh [ __ ] on with our Dynamic on the
issues that matter
this is what we need what
pseudo-intellectual nonsense from a
[ __ ] no thank you
yeah I was pregnant with the book
what
all right I I hate to flip your own game
on you Neil
but it uh it there is no possibility for
a human being a male to be pregnant with
a book that's scientifically impossible
see when you try to use your words to
try to make something sound magical I'm
shutting it down [ __ ] you don't let
these kids have Santa and Jesus and [ __ ]
guess what [ __ ] you weren't pregnant
with a book either take the take that
[ __ ] you like it
the book is actually again forgives a
uterine analogy but
I've been I've been gestating that oh my
God are you horny yes I hate no he he
bro you're you see come with yours like
one or two times you're like 80 90 times
it's also this need to eat like like
he's like our amazing analogy and I mean
he's a very big word that I can use shut
up
holy [ __ ] I love space so much because
we [ __ ] just fire you into it Jesus
Christ couldn't we put him in that
[ __ ] Tesla that's Elon shot into
space he could have been the driver
we nail you to a [ __ ] International
Space Station on the outside Christ
there you go
like Jesus ever since you told me that
no not like Jesus then you'll come back
and I don't want him to come back
hey at least we get three days without
fair enough that's a nice little
vacation
and even earlier I was observing the
world around so I got a question for you
at Neil how does it feel that Michael
Strahan went to space before you you're
the space guy yeah that gotta be like
that's got to really grind your gears
man a little bit you know
me and I'm saying man you know I would
feel if I find out that [ __ ] sucking
brother of mine that piece of [ __ ] went
to space before me I'd be furious on my
own you'll never hear the end of it
that's almost the Kevin Brennan of his
family he is
it's true this whole Community is making
I don't understand it Chad it's [ __ ]
why does Neil get to go to space I want
to go there and alienate everybody in
space
strands through coconut Sullivans I want
to go through Coke in the [ __ ] Space
Station
and don't they realize that the
statistics don't and I kept my distance
microstrated to sell tickets
who cares Michael Strahan's out of Clubs
Good Morning America's not even a real
show Chad nobody's awake it's coven
everybody works from home now they don't
get up the commute
he doesn't get to name the moons he
doesn't know the names of the moons of
Jupiter I don't know how many planets
there are
by the way on the John says it's because
Michael Strahan actually accomplished
something tangible in his life good
point it's true that's a really good
point Neil deGrasse Tyson who's just
wrote [ __ ] word salads his whole life
that's a good point like Michael Strahan
was like the NFL defensive place
the most sacks by any this beat now but
by one point he was the most sacks by
any NFL player like he did that you know
that's a really good point like oh this
mic was so great man yeah so likable
dude he really is
because I'm an astrophysicist and you
imagine getting hit by someone like
Michael Strahan they go hey so man you
okay he puts his hand on the hippie
upside man you all right and you're
bleeding from your ears and you're like
yeah I'm free man just just stay out of
my way next time yeah and he spanks to
happen every time now all right
telling you about the Hubble telescope
and all the things you want to hear from
me but I want to hear nothing from you I
want to hear Silence from you
said TJ watt tied in less games yeah
well he's never been to space [ __ ]
[ __ ] you and the goddamn Packers he was
a packer right
what no he was the oh Houston Texas
right yeah yeah [ __ ] you and [ __ ] Texas
[ __ ] you crippled governor
these observations
first moment it was I was 14.
and I'm certainly scientifically liter
[ __ ] I was early science so wait a
second he's already all he does is
not only is he smart fine whatever he's
smart but all he does is talk about how
smart he is like watch all these
interviews it's how smart he is
all right oh JJ Watt was Houston this
brother was a Steeler sorry you're right
sorry I got the watch oh yeah I
apologized honestly because I was saying
TJ watt I apologize
I apologize and there I am there was a
comment that was coming by comic kahute
oh wait I'm old I'm older than him like
I got ten dollars on you I would love to
book him
I would love to get Neil deGrasse Tyson
on a show and start talking to him and
let him get like just this like two
minutes in and then just be like
you know what get the [ __ ] out we're
done this is over get the [ __ ] out leave
so boring leave I care about any of this
I [ __ ] can't
dude uh this is the early 70s and common
kahootek is coming by we discovered it
really far I'm gonna skip ahead here
it's a great opportunity for you to go
the [ __ ] did you just say about my wife
wait what no I didn't what the [ __ ] did
you just call her oh [ __ ] a what
you said my wife's a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
kill you bro
you don't have to think takes his Rolex
off to three every fight like every guy
and you get somebody to blame so one
step backwards yeah you had been careful
about getting involved with things that
were political I mean historically yes
no no I would say that differently go
ahead yes but there's a Nuance that that
misses
I will say anything that has scientific
objectivity to it right right like your
covet stuff was really brilliant how all
of it was wrong all of it was wrong like
that genius what happened not enough
baby Hearts exploded because it wasn't
on Pluto so you didn't care
huh oh look at that you got a screenshot
of him sucking his own dick hey there it
is
regardless how of how you then interpret
it politically and I had a boatload of
these observations some of which I
shared most of which are in this book
today I can't wait to read your book
right I don't take sides all right I Do
privately I have my own opinions but I
don't view my platform if you want to
call it that as a platform to impart my
opinions on others well because then
you're [ __ ] deluding yourself then
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're
either lying to us or you're lying to
yourself anyone who thinks that they're
not using their platform to express
their personal biases he's a [ __ ]
liar you're a liar you're either lying
to us you're lying to yourself pick one
but there's no like I would never I
would never say that with a straight
face like oh yeah I mean I have my own
personal feelings but I don't make those
known on my platform what
and by the way astronauta as since you
came in late Johnny come lately they're
gonna be a replay after this it's not
going to be on locals okay that you
could watch all right sorry if you show
up and can't rewind
have your own opinions but if you
formulate an opinion why not make sure
it's as deeply informed as it could
possibly be otherwise your opinion is
dangling there on some house of cards
that has no Foundation to it there's a
point where we
Wade through the objective truths get to
the edge and now we have political hold
on hey why don't you back your opinion
up with facts because then it's facts
you [ __ ] [ __ ] but he is a [ __ ]
he's the worst remember all those sexual
assault allegations that just kind of
went away with him those were fun yeah
Texas and followers uh through the
persuasion based on fear prejudice
self-interest
um they gave us no positive opposite
there is no positive opposite to the
word demagogue and that's because the
negative works
fear he has boxed water
he's shrinking box okay can we explain
some I'm sorry this is a little tangent
I don't want to drink water out of a can
I don't care we call it liquid death and
I don't want to [ __ ] drink water out
of a box I want to drink water out of a
bottle a water bottle if you give me a
box of water or a can of water I'm not
going to open it I'm gonna smash it over
your head I don't know who started this
trend I don't know why people think the
water in a can is better but it's always
a hipster [ __ ] that I see and I guess
some people have sponsors I don't
[ __ ] know but explain to me
when I see something like this it better
have a soda in it or a beer but if it
has [ __ ] water in it those two things
should not go together dude when we were
doing Danny's show shout out to Danny
Paul's Chuck uh shout out to low value
mail uh he they had the liquid death
there and you know he's very nice he's
like hey you got any water and he's like
yeah yeah it's one in the fridge
whatever and I'm like oh thanks I mean
those those things aren't cheap either
so I'm like oh thanks but there was just
something so off-putting without
reaching for it and sipping out of a can
and getting water like your body expects
beer or something sweet or something
bitter when you're just sipping water
out of it your body is soaking like my
body at least this condition no no I'm
with you I agree and I'm like
it was just weird I'm like can I get a
glass if I drink something out of a can
it better be sweet or malty and that's
it that's it and that's it I don't want
any other flavor out of a can Okay it's
just weird I don't like it and I guess
maybe I don't know somebody said
sparkling well I guess sparkling water I
get out of a can I get that because it's
still at least it's carbonated so it
makes it's something that carbonation
should be in a can but from getting
sparkling water I want it out of a nice
bottle yes
but I don't know man but in a box of
water I don't want that either
the feeling of what will be good for you
the feeling of what justifies I think we
can be trained out of that and I have
some evidence the American physical
Society here we go which is my community
of physicists or we have a there's wow
those parties must be super fun
astrophysics group the physics group and
I'm I have a foot in both camps not a
workout group
he's such a [ __ ] Guido Meathead he
can't help himself merch we joke about
it but he does the thing too he does it
too it's not a workout group right
like uh you guys don't do leg day and
[ __ ] right because that sounds [ __ ]
bad I don't lie to you all right I got
small like genetically small legs I
gotta work on them extra hard how can
Physics help my quads to get a little
bit bigger Neil yeah how can I unlock
the power of the cosmos stuff better
calves yeah
right so the aps American physical
Society uh they have an annual meeting
all the physicists of the country oh my
God I'm not okay I can't I can't even
say that on any platform grow up it must
be a blast
huh it's okay you see he's a meathead I
told you it must be a blast
it's joking it's great it's great it's
great that's great I might share one
with you I got one for you oh no physics
joke you ready uh I'd rather not nope
we're doing it why not could we not
physics here we go maybe not it's gonna
be really good it's gonna be good here
we go here we go I like visitors
okay this is like for third graders but
it's still a physical what is the chance
any of us is going to get this joke I
have a feeling I'll get it I have a
thing you want but you're gonna pretend
you do that's what I have a feeling it's
gonna happen you're gonna totally get
through because it's for third graders
are you ready okay never trust Adams
because they make up everything
that one hurt Frozen because we're at
home now no stop Adams
did the building block of life I want to
leave
I want to go
so I left yes I did I got it
okay you know what you literally he that
killed this I'm done with the segment
that was so bad it ended the segment
holy [ __ ]
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
you know what by the way we should play
the end of it at the end of it for for
for a moment ago I don't get it
I would be the best I'll get it what
what do you mean we are the Elias
all these uh is this Adam guy lying
y'all [ __ ] them up bro Neil you're my
friend bro uh I got a friend named Adam
me you're telling me I can't trust him
because I'll call that [ __ ] sucker right
now